here we go with the taxes trump paid
only
750 in taxes both in 2016
and 2017. that's what they say okay
in 11 of the 18 years that were examined
by the times trump did not pay any
income
tax to the federal government in his
first year as a president trump or his
companies paid more taxes to india
145 grand panama roughly 16 grand
philippines 157 grand then the us
since 2000 he has lost over 315 million
dollars at the golf courses that he owns
and promotes last october trump uh tried
to steer the group of seven summit i
don't know if you remember that or not i
remember when he said we should do it at
the door al
and people took shots at them yeah the
g7 i remember that part taking place
and then in 2010 trump received a 72.9
million dollar tax refund
that is being audited by the irs he
received the sum after claiming heavy
losses
but if he loses his appeal with the irs
he will have to pay over 100 million
dollars to the federal government
anyways long story short a lot of things
came up
about his taxes wasn't pretty first day
he came up he didn't even comment on it
the second that he commented on it he
says it's fake news so after doing some
research what are your thoughts about
what
trump's taxes are looking like adam yeah
i mean any bad news that comes out
it's fake news right oh it's fake news
oh it's fake news oh it's fake news so
my question is
of all that fake news what's actually
the real news
what's actually real so there's a reason
that he's the first president
ever not to release his tax returns and
the reason that he don't want to release
his tax returns
it's right here it's pretty damn ugly so
you can either take this one of two ways
you could say well
he's a pretty shrewd businessman he
knows how to do the
do you know use the tax law to his
advantages
yeah okay that's cool or he's actually a
horrible businessman
and all he's doing is losing money
losing money losing money
and here's the next question are you
comfortable
the five percent of the people watching
this who are undecided
because as we know 90 plus percent of
people have already made up their mind
ten percent undecided ten percent are
decided five percent green
five percent completely no no no no 42
is going to vote right no matter what
yes 44 is going to vote left no matter
what 88
that's that's uh that's 86 89 42 44.
four percent is green independent
libertarian okay
ten percent is on the side of the other
side ten percent is going to be making
up their mind yep
tonight are you comfortable with your
president
paying more money in taxes to india
panama the philippines than he is to the
united states
if you're comfortable with it cool
you're it's all good vote for trump
but if you're uncomfortable with it
maybe you need to be asking yourself
what's he doing
honestly i was hoping you were going to
go deeper than that seriously no i told
you this is your show today
i want to go deeper because i have a
question this is not my way i haven't
even got a chance to even go deeper but
go ahead
so so i want to know in in what as
guardian dimension of the universe
somebody can get a 72.9 million dollar
tax refund that's a great question how
the hell does that happen would you like
to know
i would love to let me explain to you
how that works you ready
a president named obama in 2010 2011 due
to a bad
economic crisis that we were
experiencing comes
out with a tax policy that allows people
to go back because you can typically go
back to write off your losses two years
okay so you go back and you write off
your losses for two years and you can
extend it
he decides to go back four years a
hundred percent
and the fifty or fifty percent so what
does trump do he says great
his incredible accountants come out and
they say let's write off oh seven
let's write off all of o six let's write
off o5 and let's write off half of
2010 get 70 million dollars of federal
2.9 million of interest and another 20
million of state
that's because of the tax law that obama
came up with
yeah like if you're taking if you're
taking advantage of it of a tax law
that's that's out there if you don't
like it change the law but i have no
issue
with this whatsoever you know i would
love to see the the video
footage of the cnn executive i mean the
new york times executives
high-fiving each other and doing their
victory dance when they had this story
ready to go
a week before the election in 2016 the
billy bush tape comes out
it didn't affect them yeah i mean if he
can survive that this is comedy
this is light reading this is nothing
this is a mosquito
on the backside of an elephant in fact i
thought it was going to be worse
what could trump do to lose your vote no
i'm not saying it
i'm imagining it but that's not what
could trump do but i'm asking you a
different question
i'm saying he's taken trump and i don't
think there's any scandal so there's
nothing he could do to lose your vote
i'm not talking about my vote i'm
talking about
what i'm actually asking on you tom
zenner about yours not to think about it
so i'm asking you you're live on tv
right now
what could trump do as your vote ask me
let me ask tom first okay and then i'll
go to you what can you do
yeah anything man uh
it's actually very easy yeah if you
think about it it's very easy it
he could i guarantee we could what could
he do to lose your vote
i guarantee you could lose his vote drop
out of the race
i don't know so there's nothing you can
no no well you got to unpack the
question
okay if if biden and trump both if
biden's
uh uh capital gains taxes is going to be
at 25
and trump says it's going to go to 30
percent who is my vote
very simple because you're going through
an exit right not about but okay if
he raises federal taxes and biden's not
he's going to lose the vote if he
decides to not strengthen the military
to protect us and invest money to cyber
and bio warfare
he's going to lose my vote if he comes
out and next thing i know
he's befriending china becoming very
good friends with china and he's
becoming very good friends with iran
he's going to lose my vote it's very he
could easily lose my vote
this is not like oh my gosh you know oh
my god i'm so
it takes very little for me to walk into
him and be enamored by personality this
is not about
you know this is a person that's chosen
to be a president i respect the seat
tremendously whether obama or him i
still enjoy i sit there sometimes
and i watch obama's interviews because i
enjoyed watching obama's interviews
i enjoy watching the old interviews of
bill clinton i enjoy it i enjoy watching
george bush's interview sometimes
he could do things to lose my vote he
could now there are people that are
blindly following this guy and they're
just because it's republican going down
i'm not part of that camp
you have to be coming out with the right
plans the fact
that biden is too friendly to china
concerns me the fact that biden's camp
is the one that came up with 150 billion
for iran that concerns me the fact that
he's been doing this for 47 years and
still saying he can change america
and he hasn't been able to do it for 47
years that concerns me
the fact that he can be bought concerns
me these things concern me
the fact that hunter biden gets money
concerns me those things concern me the
fact that he
is not for your second amendment rights
concerns me that is the first thing that
i look at in any presidential candidate
is
that's the first one number one because
you can't have one a without 2a
and so if you're gonna if you're talking
[ __ ] about my guns you're out
so han jared so you know the first for
me
the first amendment the first amendment
yeah and then the second amendment maybe
other amendments
but the first amendment's first well i
don't think the second amendment is as
important to you as you think it is
because you ain't even strapped yet
hey you know what i basically come talk
to you when i have a gun i also don't
think it's only about
voting for trump or supporting trump
there's a lot of people that are fearful
what's going to happen
in their opinion if biden becomes
president rioting in cities
taxes going up those are things that
affect people like the writing
cities that are already going on well
yeah but that's not being
supported and promoted by the democratic
party supported and promoted
what are they what are they protesting
against oh so i should vote for biden so
the protesting and the writing will stop
what a brilliant
it's easier for trump to come out there
and say welcome to joe biden's america
this is happening in trump's america
yeah that's all i'm saying
it's not some make-believe world i'm
sure we're in trump's america right now
i'm sure you've thought about this to to
ask the question the other way what
would it take
for trump to get your vote okay i was
waiting for that question
thank you if biden actually does have
dementia and
it's not fake news you can't vote for
someone who's clearly out of their mind
so that's why i think tonight is so
important for him to step up and say
you guys are talking trash that i've
lost my mind
just like trump i just beat 16 other
candidates
and i became the nominee so should i not
so coming out of this
you could still have your vote if i
never
performed tonight i am not one of those
to put it the other way i'm not one of
those trump loyalists who no matter what
he does
he's getting my vote my vote as pat
alluded to
i'd vote for anyone if they have the
correct policies
the correct demeanor if i thought that
they'd be the best candidate for america
in 2016 i would have voted
for john kasich who's a republican
governor of ohio who finished second
in the republican platform did he not so
i'm not one of those blind followers of
anybody i get it i get it i mean you
know let's face it we can't diagnose
a guy's mental state right i mean he
could he can fumble he can
talk whatever the case is i mean he's a
little bit older so we're not going to
be able to say he has dementia
so that's not really a solid answer what
could happen
that trump can win your vote so it's he
says saying performance wise
if he doesn't perform well you know what
do you mean how do you not know if
someone does dimensions he's going to go
to a doctor he's going to get medical
records oh
you're talking about okay so you're not
talking about what do you mean i'm not
i'm not going down my eyes but literally
if they got my nose
stop stop i don't get it it's scary
because you think it's going to come out
saying he's got to mention let me give
you some ammunition
let me give you what angle this like
opposing argument should be here
here's the data let me help you out okay
bidens and kamala's tax returns came out
okay biden's tax return they just
released it right now to do it right
before the debate which is perfect
timing
brilliant move good job so biden's
return shows that he and his wife jill
made 944 thousand dollars of taxable
income last year
and paid 299 dollars at a thirty one
percent tax rate good for them they've
played
theft yeah they paid a third of their
money in taxes
okay now uh kamala's numbers came out
and herself and her husband attorney
doug emhoff reported 3
million 18 000 in taxable income kudos
to her she's a multi-millionaire
and uh the majority of it via imhoff's
partnership at global law firm dla
piper they paid federal income tax of 1
million 185 000
at a 39 tax rate biden gave away 14
700 in charitable contributions that's
1.5 percent of his income which means
he's not really a charitable guy
he just would like other people to pay
taxes but he's not really a charitable
guy
and kamala paid 35 000 in charitable uh
donations which is 1.1 percent of our
income so neither one of them are big on
charity okay
these guys pay taxes trump paid 750 in
those two years
what do you say to this that's not
what's going to get my vote or not
whether they paid them
the topic of taxes so you oh we're
talking specifically specifically
asked me what would it take for me not
to vote for biden
i don't i mean the fact that he paid his
taxes i'm not going to applaud him so so
this is a non-issue for you that trump
paid only 7.50 in a year that's a huge
issue but he did but
that that's not as big of an issue the
fact that
biden or kamala paid their taxes what do
you want me to applaud you
you paid your freaking and the fact that
they paid 30 percent
of them which is way more than say he
paid
on the list of the reasons that i would
not vote for trump
that's not shady tax wise fair enough
it's not on the line okay that's good to
know so let me i'm just saying
okay for doing what he had to do to
maneuver the tax code i'm going to give
my hand full of points you guys have
gone i've heard john i'm going to give
you my points on what i think about
these tax issues okay
and i'm looking at it from a handful of
different point of views trump's getting
backlash on this
a part of it he deserves let me explain
why here's why
when you go out there and you tweet the
following tweets i'll give you
five of his tweets okay one of his
tweets was a picture of him with his tax
return
saying signing a recent tax return isn't
this ridiculous
with a tax return this big okay and that
picture was taken and went viral
great saying oh my gosh i paid so much
taxes fine
then he said another tweet saying the
washington post loses
money and gives owner jeff bezos power
to screw public on low taxation of
amazon big tax shelter
he's calling out bezos and amazon and
washington post on what not paying a lot
of taxes
then he tweets out saying have we ever
had a president united states before
barack obama who earned over a third of
his income from foreign sources
and paid taxes to another country that's
another tweet he sent a call on barack
obama
another tweet he said that was barack
obama who wants to raise
all of our taxes only pays 20 and a half
percent
on 790 salary do i do as i say not as i
do that's another tweet and then he's
got another one that says
half of americans don't pay income taxes
despite crippling government debt
february 23 2012. so these are his
tweets
so on one end if you're going to say
this stuff you just have to be ready
if you tell me mama jokes i'm gonna tell
you mama jokes if you say stuff about my
wife you better write i'm coming after
your wife
if you talk [ __ ] about my kids it's
going down so
that part i have no problem with all the
[ __ ] talking going on on both sides
i'm very comfortable with that but i'll
tell you a couple different things you
know who got the biggest
ad and endorsement in america
in the last 72 hours trump's accounting
firm
trump's accounting firm right now is
getting non-stop calls you know why
because if you're that good at getting
me to pay this kind of taxes
i want you as my accountants that simple
i've never met anybody
that wants to pay more taxes in my
entire life
i have never met anybody that wants to
pay more taxes
if kamala and biden are so much about
giving
they should give more than 1.5 or 1.1
percent in charity they should get more
so number one
their accounting firm more power to you
number two
they say trump is a bad businessman you
hear a lot of people saying oh trump is
a bad businessman trump is a bad
businessman trump is a bad businessman
everything about capitalism and a tax
system is
set up to incentivize who
entrepreneurs why because you take the
risk
you take the loss you put up the money
and you create the jobs
you create the jobs you work 80 hours a
week you're under the stress
when people quit and they go to another
job you have to go find that person
when people are no longer you know
company following bankruptcy goes on
your record everything is on you
so the system has to be set up to
benefit who entrepreneurs more
hey if you want to pay the lower taxes
go create a job but kamala and
you know biden don't want to do it's no
problem well you have the choice that's
america set up
the other one is when they're talking
about the fact that you know how the new
york times get their hands on the irs
let me tell you this angle this angle
concerns me probably the most
out of all of them this is my biggest
concern i talk about when i think about
the uh uh new york times so what's your
source
we can't tell you really huh so who's
the only person that could give you
given you this irs local county irs or
irs
all right insider and trump's uh it's
not going to be an insider
i don't know about that it's going to be
an insider on the irs side so
why are you leaking this to new york
times so so
now my concern then becomes
which political party has influence over
the irs the right or the left
does the left control the irs because
don't forget under obama's
administration a lot of these 501 c3
plans that were coming out that were on
the right
wouldn't get approved it would take them
two three four five years to get
approved
took a long time to create these
charities i don't know if you remember
that it was very difficult for these
charities to get approval right
so what's going on with the irs why is
this information being given out
and is that problematic for me my answer
no why
very simple what wikileaks did
during the hillary clinton campaign now
these guys are doing the difference is
we knew who was wikileaks we don't know
who's the agent coming out with the irs
we don't know who the whistleblower is
that concerns me why because they can do
that to anybody
anybody they can do that to you to you
to you you say one wrong thing if they
wanted to they can come after you
you know we're talking about all this
stuff and stuff is going around the
world that nobody knows about and we
forget about how amazing america is
check this out an american is facing two
years in prison after leaving a bad trip
advisor review for thailand resort
let me say this one more time an
american is facing two years in prison
after leaving a bad trip advisor review
for a thailand resort
here's a review unfriendly staff no one
ever smiles
they act like they don't want anyone
here the restaurant manager was the
worst he is from czech republic
he's extremely rude and impolite to
guests find another place
there are plenty people plenty of places
with nicer staff that are happy you are
staying with them
he comments then in another review he
says modern day slavery
is what he posts and then he takes it
down so what do they do
we chose to follow a complaint to sort
of a deterrent and we want we understand
continue to write a negative review week
after week have a foreseeable future
thailand has strict anti-defamation laws
which can lead to lengthy prison
sentences or fines
a defamation of application conviction
can lead to two years of prison sentence
sixty three hundred dollar fine this guy
is facing two years of prison
okay well hey i applaud it first time an
internet troll has actually been
punished
all right so that's good number two what
happens if you steal a towel
right can you imagine you take a rogue
you take a towel what they're gonna do
to you in thailand and third you better
know the laws of where you're traveling
yeah especially a place like thailand
you go there you think anything goes
right it's a pretty loose society but
man you start doing something like that
you have no idea the repercussions so
the biggest thing i'm saying is man how
lucky we are to live in america where
you can say whatever you want to say
the moment you lose that you talk about
freedom of speech any time about guns
the moment you lose those two things man
it's a scary place